[Music]
over the years I have watched so many
like I used to work at CERN at live
years and years ago and over the years
I've watched so many people started
signing out live go all the way through
great time and then they depart and it's
it's emotional it is very emotional it's
very weird it's also weird to just leave
the city - because New York is it's
you're just you're on the hometown team
kind of and they have no problem with
telling you what they thought of the
show on the streets or anything like
that I was walking with my in-laws once
and I was walking with my in-laws in a
cab pulled up and this guy pulled the
the window down anyone hey yes I know
you and your show
my the knight said I said it was a guy
who worked at the shows I got Robbie
that's Robbie's plain old joke the
biggest insult there is yes I know
yeah that's what I did hearing you got a
name they show they're like hey that's
the no that was great last night yeah
they never open their eyes hey no that's
that guy he's gonna hunt you your home I
have my whole life I just moved to Los
Angeles
you still think